hello and welcome back to the shiki-san
- so today we'll look at the question of
kind genetics is they in weight gain so
how did you gain weight so to kind of
put it simply you have energy in and you
have a plan that you out and so if
they're the same then your weights
shouldn't variously the same but when we
have weight gain what happens is you
have energy in is greater than energy
Alex and so if energy in is greater than
energy outs for chronic time periods it
can result in weight gain and eventually
lead to obesity
so energy in pretty much comes down to
you food intake what it is that you eat
energy outs it's a bit more complicated
so that can be accounted for by your
basal metabolism just to sustain your
body it can also be accounted for by
physical activity the more you need
balance the more energy you burn and the
last thing is adaptive thermogenesis so
adaptive thermogenesis is pretty much
just the burning of heat in response to
environmental changes in temperature and
items but can this be influenced by our
genetics and what contributions are
there from the environment as well so
most people seem to think that obesity
or having too much weight is down to a
lack of willpower but actually there's a
lot of evidence now that supports the
genetic role in terms of regulating food
intake and energy output indeed there
are certain genetic mutations that if
they occur in just one gene it results
in obesity and weight gain and these are
called monogenic disorders
so an example of a monogenic cause of
obesity was first identified in rice one
mouse imaginatively named obese it was
effectively found out to have a mutation
in the gene encoding the hormone leptin
now Lupton's
actually really important for the
regulation of food intake so a leptin is
secreted from adipose tissue so fat fat
tissue and this is released into the
bloodstream leptin then travels in the
blood up into the brain where the
it combined to the leptin receptors and
the leptin receptors can trigger a
response in the brain that eventually
signals to promote energy expenditure
and to prevent food intake it also has
the consequence of promoting great and
affecting blood pressure but it's
important to raise at this this moment
that this is highly simplified and there
are many things that we table fully
understand in terms of leptin is
response yet but the key thing to point
out is that the mermouse example where
there was a mutation in the leptin gene
resulted in reduced leptin levels which
therefore prevented the signaling of
preventing food intake this had the
consequence for resulting in an
increased weight gain and the obese
phenotype seen in the obese mice and
leptin is not the only monogenic case
that we have found the signaling system
i've described in the brain there are
many different protein components
whether they're receptors or submarine
products
that also have mutations that are seen
in monogenic causes of obesity I will go
into these different proteins in more
detail next time
but these monogenic causes of weight
gain and obesity are quite broad
how can we account for common obesity
well it turns out that obesity and
weight gain is a very complex process
there are many different genes that can
contribute and hence it's a polygenic
condition but what evidence is there for
this so one line of evidence comes from
what are known as genome-wide
Association studies so these studies are
observational studies that look at a set
of genetic variants and different
individuals to see if any variants are
associated with a particular trait in
this case a high body mass index
notice here that ta mg prefer two
different variants of a particular
genetic loci so those are different
genetic glassing are analyzed but then
comes the tricky part trying to work out
which ones of these less I are actually
causal as opposed to just a correlation
that's
having the variants and having a higher
body mass index this can only come from
looking at each lucite individually
however from a genome-wide Association
study we can try and look at low-side
that are more significant than others
themes are best represented through what
are known as Manhattan plots whereby you
plots the likelihood or the significance
of each low sigh associated with the
higher body mass index
with the DNA along the x axis and the
called Manhattan plots because well they
look kind of like the skyline of
Manhattan so in my simple representative
sketch and you can see that majority of
the different low site in the DNA one
significant they didn't surpass the
threshold but there are a few nasai that
do and are relatively significant and
these are the low side interest so what
are these low side then and has a
genome-wide Association study actually
been done for body mass index so let's
look at some real data which will put my
little sketch to shame so this study was
conducted in 2015 and it is what I've
been describing
it's a genome-wide Association study
that is lips hat genetic variants that
are more frequent in people with a
higher body mass index so with their
study they identified 97 low sigh which
when I looked at teams associated with
the set-aside they were found to be
enriched in processes such as energy
metabolism lipids biology and a deeper
genesis which is fat production okay so
that's pretty cool but the problem is is
that most of these laïcité are actually
in non-coding regions what this means is
that they're not actually altering the
genes themselves that altering maybe the
expression pattern of those genes we
just didn't really know at the moment so
how does that prove that these genetic
variants are causal for altering the
body mass index so without fully
understanding what these variants are
doing we can generate what are known as
polygenic risk scores so polygenic risk
scores
take into account multiple genetic
variants and can be used to predict body
mass index and so when this is done
across the population you are not
normal distribution of people who have
assassin score and this can be used to
correlate with the body mass index as
I've drawn out here whether or not these
risk horns are even useful was a whole
kind of feeding on itself but the point
I'm trying to demonstrate here is that
they have been done for body mass index
and they D seem to correlate with body
mass index their predictable to some
extent and therefore it does kind of
underpin the fact that genetics is
really important for understanding body
mass index and obesity incidents so yes
weight gain and body mass is complicated
but it is really important to understand
it because obesity puts you at risk for
type 2 diabetes cancer and
cardiovascular disease these are some of
the leading causes of death in our
society but by understanding the genetic
underpinning it helps us to better
understand why we may gain weight and
identify good targets for therapeutics
so you can genetics we'll stay awake in
knots entirely but it's definitely
important